foreign
I'm not ready
I'm never ready for anything but all
right
be all right do you guess
get some of that eggnog
I don't really like eggnog all that much
I'm gonna drink it all well yeah that's
why who you like yeah you can get it I
drink all that I want some hot chocolate
with some whipped cream in it and a
candy cane That's all I want yeah and my
it might have two episodes yeah yeah
okay and it's gotta have whipped cream
in it too okay I got whipped cream
I got everything for chocolate milk too
I don't think we have no candy canes
though I have to go to Dollar just to
get a dollar yeah you got them at a
Dollar General Yeah we actually got some
you got some good uh chocolate candy
bars over the other day yeah they were
real big with like real big ones I guess
that was like the Dollar General version
of of like garibald of the of the um
yeah Ghirardelli or like the deluxe one
they were like sea salt and caramel or
something like that they come in a box
they're not quite as soft they're kind
of crunchy but that's okay you know it's
it's nuts for a dollar that's pretty
goddamn good big old for a big huge
chocolate bar with caramel and salted
yeah right that's a cardboard box my
cheap ass I'm not I'm not proud yeah
I'll eat that [ __ ] all day long yeah Ben
says for Christmas you can have diabetes
yeah probably it does run in my family I
probably should be careful okay so
hateful eight we watched it this is also
kind of a Christmas movie yeah it kind
of isn't it yeah doesn't it take place
like right around Christmas time yeah I
think it does actually I think they
mentioned it um
so we've been we've been doing uh uh oh
what's his name Quentin
Tarantino's movies and I remember seeing
bits of this but this is the first time
I've seen it uh from the complete yeah I
was gonna say too I thought that I'd
seen the whole thing all the way through
but watching it again I don't think I
ever did I thought I just like saw parts
of it yeah but I never like sat through
the whole thing we had two options that
they had on there they had the
theatrical release and they had another
one it was five episodes I think well
they did that one um I looked it up
later they did that in 2019 for Netflix
so they essentially just re-edited it
and um you know put some stuff back in
it that was in there because I guess the
the cut that we watched was just the
theatrical version which was like two
hours and 47 minutes or something now he
also did a theatrical version that was
three hours and two minutes but the one
that's on Netflix I guess it's been
re-edited and had some footage added
edited back in it and it they did it
like four it was four or five episodes
right they were at least they were like
54 minutes long something like that we
were gonna watch that but then I was
like holy [ __ ] it'll be like one in the
morning before it's like I'll fall
asleep before it's over so we just
watched the theatrical cut and this that
wasn't the cut that people had asked us
to review
when they're talking about this movie
when we're talking about the smoother
usually talking about the theatrical cut
so maybe we'll see the other one later
yeah
um but uh this this is the theatrical
cuts the short version it's good I liked
it I mean just relatively short it's
still pretty long but you know what I
mean a half hours long but um
uh I was impressed with the movie this
is definitely one of his better ones uh
uh I put it up you put it up there with
you know once upon a time in Hollywood
and Pulp Fiction it's a very different
from Pulp Fiction he's definitely doing
a spaghetti western
even with the even with the uh with the
score he's got a good score goddamn the
score for this it's so good yep it's uh
it's it's filmed outside in real snow
yeah it's it's uh shot in uh Colorado
actually it's supposed to be Wyoming but
they shot it in Colorado yeah tally ride
costumes are good set's good it's all
taking place in one one place but it's a
it's a good
spaghetti western done Tarantino style
and overall
the movie is a bromance
basically between three dudes that
[ __ ] have a lot of differences they
can't stand each other
Bounty Hunter who's kind of neutral
a black Union major who got who
basically got run out as a coward
uh and he lies some and uh then a son of
a Confederate
commander who he also fought On A
Confederacy like uh he's played by the
dude that played the psycho in [ __ ]
Predators which uh yeah that seems in a
bunch of stuff this is the only other
movie I've seen him in he did a great
job in this he's in a lot of kind of
like Prestige TV he was on that show
Justified I think that's probably what
he's best known for he was like he's in
like a bunch of stuff so crosso plays
the Bounty Hunter
and uh uh [ __ ] Samuel L Jackson plays
the uh the the the the major the union
who is also a bounty hunter right yeah
he's a bounty hunter too and
um they can't stand each other but in
the end
they they're there for each other they
resolve their differences and [ __ ]
they're all kind of equally honorable
slash dishonorable
and they deliver Frontier Justice
that's what it's about Frontier Justice
and they're gonna [ __ ] hang this
chick who's a prisoner and uh she's
she's a gang leader and she's good at it
too uh she gotta Oscar for this yeah
Best Supporting she doesn't say a whole
lot in the edit that we saw but she does
a lot of good physical acting like uh
she just
beat up and dirty looking and I mean
he's punched in the face they're beating
her up a lot in this movie he's real
Divine she's real defiant
and then sometimes she just tries to be
cute as hell well you know it's it's
just funny he's got to run a damn chain
and uh and then in the end when she
finally kind of gets free a little bit
because her brother tries to come to
rescue her and she starts
actually having a bigger active role in
the move you find out [ __ ] how evil
she is you know it's pretty damn evil
yeah and um smart
but it's a good flick it takes a while
for it to unfold Bruce derns in it plays
a confederate general at [ __ ]
Samuel Jackson tells him the story about
how he made his son suck his dick that's
like the best yeah that's the best part
of the hole
in a Samuel L Jackson can I just say
[ __ ] steals this well he kind of
steals every movie that he's in that's
just because he's just so awesome but I
mean it that's really saying something
an ensemble cast as amazing as this one
like he just picks up this movie and
runs the [ __ ] away with it and that's
like the best scene yeah Jackson's
reminded me of my friend will and that's
where I was like man it's like will yeah
we have a friend that looks uh a lot
like that
big tall X army black guy who's in the
god scene with me and I got a good video
of him me and him on the street and I'm
[ __ ] loaded and he's got his arm
around me trying to talk Santa to me or
something he's trying to complete my
sentences because I'm just so [ __ ] up
that was pretty [ __ ] funny yeah I'm
barely holding it together he might have
been drunk too oh yeah yeah no we'll
drink as much as I can just you know
he's bigger
and he can kind of hold it together yeah
though yeah he doesn't usually get like
real no I just start getting quiet yeah
when I get real loaded I'd start I can't
talk so other people my friends have to
talk for me
[Laughter]
like Samuel Jackson he's [ __ ] funny
big old looks like him too well yeah
there was a scene in here it didn't
really occur to me until there was one
scene where he was like talking and they
showed his face I was like holy [ __ ]
that looks just like well yeah and like
well even like his facial expressions
and stuff like that it was like super
funny yeah his his uh wife slash
girlfriend I don't think they got
married did it
um not yet I don't think they got
married yet his uh his uh I have a
fantastic girlfriend is a
uh Army captain or major she's still
active she's in Med she's medical I
think she's like a type of doctor
we ought to have him over one time he'd
be good guests on the show he probably
would be yeah yeah you get a drug he's
[ __ ] funny he's very entertaining
yeah show up in his damn kill yeah he
would tell you over and over again how
Scottish American he is
I just give it to him I go yeah okay
yeah he likes bagpipe music and [ __ ]
but uh yeah so anyway
it's a good movie
it's a great it's a good Western it's a
very good Western it it does go a little
Tarantino on you but that's why you
that's why you're watching this I mean
that's kind of his yeah you know he's
gonna do that he's homage and some
Sergio Leone every now and then
especially with the score so he knew
what to do I mean really what made a
good Western was the score and as Sergio
Leone really introduced the idea of damn
score to a to a a western movie because
that's what makes a a western feel
important and go back and look go back
and listen good and the bad you're ugly
and all the the uh The Man With No Name
series or I guess it's a Trilogy and
those movies feel very important and
it's because of the it's because of the
school yeah because they're epic yeah
well and that's why ennio morricone does
the score for this this was I think this
was the last score he did before he died
he only died a couple years ago
[Music]
um
and yeah and uh actually the thing about
it yeah I love the score for this it's
great and I think even though any of
moroccone had been nominated for several
Oscars for best score I think this is
the only one that he won yeah and you
know what's interesting too Richard
Brown says the thing done as a western
uh which it kind of is I guess I
mentioned this in the program is that
um actually Anya morricone did some
music for the thing okay and there were
three songs that he did that they didn't
use in the movie but Quentin Tarantino
used them in this movie okay so they're
still there's still any immoricornia but
they were originally composed for the
thing there's basically a shout out to
the thing in the movie I'm watching it
and the stagecoach driver
Adobe yeah OB if you look at him he's
wearing the same outfit as crossables
wearing in the thing that's that's
that's mccready's [ __ ] helicopter
pilot outfit
yep he had the big hat Smokey the bear
hat so he didn't have the front of it
pulled up
and he had the little glasses with the
side protectors
and that's bomber jacket it was a lot
like a bomber jacket and the same beard
and everything and you go so
the stagecoach driver in the [ __ ]
snow is also McCready in the snow
flying the helicopter
yeah I saw that
but he did use some music from from the
thing yeah well music that was initially
composed for the thing but they didn't
use it in the movie okay you know what I
mean but it was still any more corny but
this was actually
um I think this also even to this
present day is the only movie that had
the only Quentin Tarantino movie that
had an original score composed for it
because usually he does you know music
like he picks like old music I was
watching it you know I didn't know any
of this Jenny did you know I'm just
watching these things like a normal
person she didn't come back and do all
the investigation of who did what but
novice I was calling it I was going that
that's an epic [ __ ] score I didn't
realize it was the same dude that did
all the spaghetti well I told you though
because his name came up on the his name
came up on the on the credit because I
told you I guess it didn't register and
I was like oh it's any of morricone okay
I didn't know who you were talking about
oh you didn't know yeah oh I don't know
that is I thought you knew who that was
and I was just going man this is a
[ __ ] badass score and that's what
made
makes a really good Western and some uh
you know some of Clint Eastwood's movies
had good enough score you know I mean he
didn't have an epic score it wasn't like
an Italian score the Italians understand
[ __ ] epic Opera [ __ ] you know
they know how to write music for that
oh they got a long Heritage of it in the
in their theaters
so uh but even even
um in high plays in the high Pantry what
was it uh yeah High Plains Drifter and
um a [ __ ] Pale Rider they had decent
scores they they also feel you outlaw
Josie or whales they weren't quite as
epic as Italian but they were good
enough
yeah uh well I thought you were gonna
say something else no why would I say
anything else well I don't know
I never I never know when you're done
talking Yeah because sometimes I think
you're not talking
no no so it's like I'm always kind of
waiting it's like is he not talking I'm
not sure because I'm never sure but um I
want to say too that this was shot in 70
millimeter so it's just like the old
school like movies from the 50s and
stuff that were like that wide wide
widescreen he went back old school
because he wanted it to be like this big
huge like Epic
kind of thing you know what I mean this
was I think originally this was supposed
to be he initially conceived it as a
sequel to Django Unchained which had
come out in uh 2012 right I haven't seen
it and yeah I don't think I've seen
Django Unchained either now that I'm
thinking about it
um but this was supposed to be a sequel
to that and he was going to write it as
the sequel that he was going to do like
a novel
and
so what ended up happening though was
that the script for this movie kind of
like leaked out and so he's like well
[ __ ] now I'm just gonna do it a novel
but then he's like you know what [ __ ] it
and then he just like changed it around
a little and I think that he thought
maybe that even though the I think the
Samuel L Jackson character was supposed
to be kind of like I don't know I think
it was supposed to be like a
continuation of what happened in Django
Unchained but then he decided it would
be you know that it was going to be too
different so it was going to be like a
standalone but he definitely want to do
another Western he said that he got the
idea for this not necessarily from
Spaghetti Westerns but he said like from
those old western tv shows like The Big
Valley and stuff he's like they'd always
have or The Virginian or whatever he's
like they'd always have on those shows
they'd always be like one or two
episodes where all the good guys would
be like you know kind of Taken hostage
or like take like and like they would
all be trapped in this place like with
all these other guys that you didn't
know if they were good guys or bad guys
and he's like so I wanted do a movie
like that but where everybody
in it was like a bad guy and you didn't
know uh who was telling the truth and he
was lying like at any time and so it
also had that kind of like who done it
like like mystery kind of aspect to it
because there comes that thing like if
you haven't seen it where they're all
trapped in this you know place it's like
a lodge or something like that and
they're all trapped there because of a
blizzard and you know they're all kind
of like
they're all kind of bad people you know
what I mean nice or you know varying
degrees of bad I guess yeah I'm gonna
have to see Django's Unchained they're
talking about it in the comments yeah
yeah I'm gonna have to see that now I
didn't know that he did I didn't know
that Tarantino made real good westerns
but it was a pretty good Western man
yeah I mean
it's a it's a gorgeous looking Western
it's just like I said it's just this
wide sweeping like epic yeah it's uh
almost kind of like um Jeremiah Johnson
Level yeah it's like somebody Jeremiah
Johnson
good movie and I liked too we were
talking about this while we were
watching it
um Tom's like I like that he kind of
showed I think that maybe a couple
people that saw it like thought that it
went on too long like some of the
sequences went on too long like for
example when they were
um you know to taking the horses off the
carriage or like doing the line out to
the
Outhouse and the stables and stuff like
that in the middle of the blizzard and
everything like that but Tom was like
well I kind of like that they're showing
that because like a lot of westerns they
don't show like what a pain in the ass
everything used to be back in the old
days and like how [ __ ] long
everything took yeah because that's the
one scene where the blizzard is coming
and they're like well we better like lay
a line out too so we can get to the
Outhouse and we can get to the stable
and feed the horses and stuff like that
like without blowing away or getting
lost or whatever if those who don't know
me I grew up in the horse industry my
mother's pretty famous trainer
and when me and Jenny met at that time I
was taking care of a rich guy's [ __ ]
Barn
and um that was some of the things that
I do in between
other military type Jobs is
be a ranch hand that's
so I just grew up doing that and feeding
taking care of horses and if people
don't realize how labor intensive it is
man it's not like a car where you can
just park it walk away from it
got a clean stalls [ __ ] pick Hooves
[ __ ] grooming medication fee feet up
turn out
uh wash rack
you know they're a living creature you
gotta be on them all the time and under
those conditions that they were showing
blizzard coming
if you didn't take steps you'd lose some
horses they'd freeze to death in that
you know so but they would have had the
equipment around keep those horses
blankets and stuff putting big blankets
on them they probably would have patched
everything up so there wouldn't be any
wind blowing in
that was one of the things I was looking
at where they were living man the cracks
in between the damn boards wind would
have been blowing right through that
thing yeah one shot I saw it was like I
don't know how accurate that was they
knew how to build buildings back in the
1800s they were you know
they didn't have Central Heating and Air
so they knew how to get airflow or shut
it off during the winter they knew about
insulation too so it was maybe might
have just been for effect you know
I mean uh
that looked like a pretty well-built
building
well we don't know how long that
building's been there it's like you know
maybe they you know maybe they don't get
a lot of people in there they don't have
a lot of money to like yeah they fix
[ __ ] up or something like that I like
eighth of an inch it looked like an
eighth of an inch difference in between
all the boards on the walls that one
shot I don't know maybe it might have
been Just an Illusion to the camera but
did you see what I was talking about yes
okay
but um yeah they because I was watching
it and I'm sitting there going because
you know how a lot of times like when
you see a movie and you can tell that
the snow is not real you know what I
mean and you can tell that it's not
really cold too like I feel like it's
better now because at least you can like
add some [ __ ] in digitally later on but
even then it still kind of looks fake so
I'm like watching this going that does
absolutely not look fake that is all
real snow and that it actually looked
like a real blizzard I'm imagining it
was not but
um it looked like it looked really good
yeah everybody looked like they were
freezing their [ __ ] ball yeah the
outside shots yeah but like I said so I
looked it up because like I said it was
supposed to be Wyoming but they actually
did shoot it in Colorado so the weather
you know that they're like yeah we're
gonna shoot it like right in the middle
of the winter I guess but I mean it
looked really realistic yeah I thought
yeah because you can really tell that
fake snowflake looks really really bad
and then that carriage the shots of them
inside that Carriage yeah yeah and a lot
of a lot of stuff a lot of cool stuff
kind of happens you know picking guys up
on the side of the road and not being
able to trust them and tell them to put
their guns on the ground and uh then
wanted to handcuff them you know when
they were coming into the to the
carriage they had to strap the the
Frozen dead guys to the top of carriage
I love that there's um
just a lot of a lot of cool little
details that are included in the story
because you know Victorian era Wild West
life it was rough man you had to do [ __ ]
like that it was very manual you
couldn't just get on your phone and call
for help you couldn't
um you know just get put some fuel in a
vehicle and just drive it you know it's
not it wasn't that easy yeah I mean it's
so much easier right nowadays I can't
imagine how much [ __ ] and you know
it's like net I I go through [ __ ]
nowadays where it's like man that's such
a pain in the ass to do this that and
the other thing but it's like back then
holy crap it's like how the [ __ ] did
they get anything done yeah everything
must have taken forever nowadays you
could get into a car and a dead a winter
turn the damn air conditioning on get it
hot in there and drive around your
T-shirt and Total Comfort inside that
vehicle man it was never like that it
actually wasn't even like that in the
1920s you've been freezing your ass off
in that [ __ ] car well yeah well then
you can see it happen now like sometimes
if you know if it's the middle of winter
somewhere where it gets really cold like
in Michigan or something the power goes
out like people actually absolutely do
free stuff like it's inside their houses
it happens all the time or like you know
homeless people and stuff so I do kind
of feel like um but yeah you can
definitely tell this was shot somewhere
where it was actually he did it cold he
did a good job he did a real good job of
making a a
real Western
like you said it's you know you know
tarantino-esque so it's over the top and
it has some kind of like ridiculous kind
of elements to it
but that's that's his thing I mean
that's what you watch a Tarantino movie
yeah if you think of Sergio Leone movie
isn't ridiculous you need your [ __ ]
head checked all kinds of [ __ ] would
happen and then in Sergio's flicks that
couldn't have happened in real life but
you're just you're you're enjoying the
movie yeah though yeah and the movie
still comes off as epic and important
um
what was a little bit different about
this is they're basically snowed in so
it's all a lot of it has taken place
just in one room yeah
um which I guess that does save on some
money but they didn't scrimp I mean you
know it's
shooting outside with horses and in the
snow and everything that's [ __ ] it's
tedious it's a massive cast yeah it's
like a you know it's a big so yeah it's
still it's still it's a good movie I
think this cost about I've seen 44
million or and I've seen 65 million so
somewhere in that range that's where uh
you know that's how much it costs to
make which actually I would have thought
it was would have been more but I guess
not yeah it looks more expensive than
that but like I said yeah it does most
of its dialogue too it does have good
dialogue everybody's telling their own
little story pretty much
and uh there's kind of uh morality Tales
into what they're talking and then you
know it it affects the destiny of each
one of these characters
and um you know spoiler alert everybody
dies in it
pretty much pretty much yeah I mean they
kind of do don't they I think everybody
dies
now that I'm thinking about it I don't
think anybody
yeah yeah spoiler alert but it does kind
of divide into good guys and bad guys
even though the good guys didn't like
each other
you know and they were all imperfect
characters
there wasn't anybody that the club like
you think there is one you you think the
uh you think Samuel L Jackson's
character is like a stand-up good dude
you find out later now he's he's a liar
yeah he's a liar he's a liar and uh and
he was a coward well he was he was a
coward in the service got run out they
ran up put a yellow stripe up his back
and ran him out but he wasn't a coward
in real life he was still a [ __ ]
badass Bounty Hunter you know I did I
don't think they gave the details of why
they ran him out it might have been a
bum wrap you don't know
yeah I mean they did tell the story of
him like burning down that prisoner War
Camp that's right is that what it was
but yeah they ran him out for that
um yeah was it be was it for that or was
it for something else I don't think it
was oh no because I guess yeah I guess
he had done something else and then they
imprisoned him in that and then he
escaped by like burning it down yeah
yeah
but but then he he eventually got well
he was in a he was a prisoner War he
escaped yeah
but his own Army [ __ ] ran him out as
a coward yeah and I don't think they
told the story of why
yeah did they I don't remember if they
did I mean maybe it's in the maybe it's
in the longer version because I know
there was they shot a lot more yeah
footage for this so you know I'm not
really sure and kind of the whole thing
is about
I mean I kind of feel like the whole
thing is about one coincidences like
because everybody like you know meeting
up people on the road like at this one
little place and everyone kind of knows
each other they don't know each other
necessarily but they know of each other
like hey you're that famous you know
gang leader you're that famous bounty
hunter or whatever so it's like
everybody knows who everybody is but
even though they've never actually met
each other mostly
um but it's also about kind of it's just
a lot of it is about the stories that
people are telling each other and
there's kind of a thing too like where
you're never entirely sure if like what
the story they're telling is [ __ ] or
like for example the story that Samuel L
Jackson's character tells to broussern's
character about his son like what he
made his son do like before he killed
him and [ __ ] like that it's like did
that really happen or was he just
telling him that like to get a rise out
of him the Confederate guy you don't
know Confederate guy was saying man he's
lying don't listen to him he didn't do
that
but uh he's just he just wanted to shoot
him
he remember he just wanted to shoot that
dude well yeah because there was a line
like toward the beginning where they
said oh you're gonna shoot an unarmed
old man and that's why he put that gun
there next to him like and he didn't
give it to him or nothing he just put it
there and then like he started then he
started [ __ ] with him like saying all
the [ __ ] that he would like did to his
son yeah like making him walk out there
naked and like making it yeah because
his son was trying to collect a bounty
on him there was uh the union had a
better
yeah the union still had a bounty on him
wouldn't it or no the Confederacy had he
had a bounty on him yeah well they said
that at one point like the Bounty was
what'd they say was like it's some
ridiculous it's not like 30 000. but
yeah but by the time the sun was like it
was only 5 000 but I mean still five
thousand dollars was nothing to sneeze
at all that stuff's kind of accurate
after the after the Civil War
ex-confederate soldiers still did a lot
of [ __ ] like Jesse James was robbing
banks and he
he seemed to have been maybe saving up
money to try to start another Rebellion
I don't think it was the lost cause I
don't think it would have happened but
um
ex-confederates were doing things like
trying to take revenge on people that
they had beef against still during the
wars that that did go on and the Lee
family ran to Brazil their descendants
are still in Brazil
a lot of people don't know that there's
a damn Confederate colony in Brazil it's
been there since the 1800s they speak
English and everything
yeah
tourist attraction yeah Brazilians go
there to see it yeah well yeah several
hundred of them
say hey Jen's here hey how are you doing
I think this is the first time you've
ever yeah Jan okay because Dimitri comes
into the chat sometimes yeah every now
and then yeah but this I think this is
the first time we've seen you in the
chat though so I showed pictures of Jen
before uh from the club
Jen's a singer from 13th angel
um
yeah she uh her her husband is a DJ to
the club we hang out at Dimitri yeah
he's in here every now and then but I
haven't seen him in here for a while
y'all need to come over once I get
everything all hooked up in here try to
get damn bar built over here in this
living room this top living room one of
these days yeah once I get the money
yeah
yeah yeah Dominic says have you seen the
big Silence of the film this movie is
heavily influenced by I don't think I
ever have actually
I don't think I ever have but um but
yeah like I said I was just reading
something earlier about how uh Tarantino
was using a lot of the
the TV westerns like as a kind of thing
but
I don't know just everything about this
is [ __ ] great I don't like that I
don't like it as much as Pulp Fiction
um but I think that's just mainly
because Westerns aren't usually my thing
but
I don't know there's a there's a really
a lot about like all of the characters
in this are good like all of their
interactions are good like
I the funny thing about it though I kind
of feel like there's a
I don't know there's like this kind of
like humor kind of thing where they keep
repeating the same line over and over
like this kind of like dry like a letter
from Abraham Lincoln President Abraham
believed like they say like five or six
yeah yeah and it's just kind of like and
like after a while I was like it's it's
kind of not funny but then like it keeps
going and then it's funny again I don't
know what it is well they were joking
around too right right the characters
were joking around
so I think it was cool you know there's
this decent dialogue some of that stuff
though kind of rings true because they
didn't have internet back then they
didn't have television or even radio
so they would go to saloons and bars and
just talk about people and tell stories
and they would keep track of people I
mean a lot of a lot of stuff from the
old west those gunfighters their Legends
lived on because people talked about
them and people wrote stuff in
newspapers about them and so they were
gossiping [ __ ] that's what they
did well yeah humans are gossiping yeah
[ __ ] so so there's something to this
concept of look oh you're that guy oh
yeah I heard about you there should have
been there's probably a lot of that
because the population density was low
real low
so
if you went into your bar
that might include people from 30 miles
around maybe 40 miles yeah because this
might have been like the only way you
know yeah the only one you know well and
that seems to be the case here because
the you know the place they all end up
at many is Haberdashery you're kind of
led to believe that this is kind of the
the Main Place everybody stops on the
way to Red Rock which is like on the way
to the next big town you know what I
mean yeah so everybody stops at this
place like to get food and
you know sleep and booze or whatever
like you can get everything there so I
guess that's kind of why that happens
and everybody just kind of goes there
because it's like famous
but I don't know I just I don't I just
really really liked I liked the mystery
aspect of it too like I had forgotten
because like I said I never actually saw
this whole movie all the way through
like I had just seen parts of it and I
kind of just remembered it being like a
bunch of them just trapped in the in the
lodge or whatever and them like
you know shooting each other which they
do but it's I forgot that there was like
a mystery aspect to it like somebody
poisoned the coffee and they're trying
to figure out who was working with who
and who was making [ __ ] up and who
wasn't who they said they were so it's
almost kind of like a Agatha Christie
like a parlor kind of mystery but like
in a western setting which actually is
like a kind of a cool idea yeah that's
also something that they would have done
that's Victorian era yeah they had you
know
uh detective stories and everything so
you know that would have been part of
their skill set well he did that you
know
you can't understand there was no
professional law enforcement you know
you just had to
if you had to reason it out you know
and that's what they did
they were talented you know those
characters are pretty talented I also it
was The Poisoned that coffee I also
liked too that the movie for like the
first
for like you know 90 of it is with like
the people like talking and just doing
[ __ ] like that and then like in the last
15 minutes it just goes bad [ __ ] gory
like people like [ __ ] blowing each
other's nuts off and like cutting each
other's arms off yeah [ __ ] like that
it's like [ __ ] hilarious yeah it's
hilarious but uh yeah I just really
liked all and I think uh nicotero and
them yeah knb did the uh the gore for
this because it is like pretty gory and
it's up there with uh when you think
about it you go well you know that's
kind of Quentin Tarantino doing his
thing that's also homage and stuff that
from that time yeah stories of Jeremiah
Johnson are [ __ ] off the wall
that he gets captured by The Crow
and while they got him they're trying
the crow are trying to sell Jeremiah to
another tribe who wants him dead
he overpower is one of the crow dudes
and [ __ ] kills him cuts his leg off
the leg uses that leg to beat another
crowd again all right to escape the calf
that never fails and then it walks over
like 150 miles through the snow with
that leg
non on it for nutrition to make it and
that is a real Jeremiah Johnson story it
probably didn't happen probably not
those dudes lied they told all kind of
story you know even the whole Jim Bowie
you know with the Bowie knife thing they
say Jim Bowie was a liar too that he
killed a grizzly bear with that knife
you know what I mean in a fight and just
all kinds of [ __ ] I mean it's possible
it's just unlikely got in those bars and
he would [ __ ] drink and they'd
[ __ ] lie and tell stories but but I
think that was just part of the part of
the of the of the West skill set was to
be entertaining
you know and if you were to tell some
big old [ __ ] lie I think that
I think that the audience just like
appreciated would just appreciate it
yeah that's a pretty good lie that's a
good it's like watching a movie
yeah because they didn't have movies
back then yeah well didn't we talk about
this a little bit when we were talking
about I guess what was when we were
talking about the Tombstone the movie
Tombstone right where it's just kind of
like
um I think wasn't it Tombstone that we
were talking about where one of the
themes like behind the thing was
um you know the difference between like
real [ __ ] and like the Romantic the you
know the way it's romanticized I guess
no that was Unforgiven not not Tombstone
what am I doing yeah it was unforgiving
like how a lot of the stories are like
uh romanticizing but a lot of the like
truth about it was like not no no it's
glamorous as it sounded it was crime
right so it was like I think this one is
kind of like playing with the similar
idea but it's just going balls to the
wall yeah we're just gonna go like
just over the top like the stories back
then would have been yeah you know what
I mean it's like yeah we're gonna blow
off somebody's face and like block
somebody's nuts and yeah you know yeah
Jennifer Jason lay cuts off Kurt
Russell's arm like to get to get the
[ __ ] cuffs off her and [ __ ] like that
so I'm watching it you know and I'm
watching Tarantino do his thing you know
but I was going this kind of checks out
though yeah it kind of checks out with
the with the with with with the Gestalt
of the time because they would tell tall
tales
and uh they cussed too I think the car I
think the cursing in there is probably
pretty accurate oh yeah I imagine so
it's just
they didn't write curses down but
evidently you know they did say oh yeah
this stupid cuss and this and that you
know [ __ ] they never really tell you
what it was but it was probably [ __ ]
like that you know
you suck my [ __ ] that kind of stuff you
know the you know so I think that's
probably the way it was
and um
no I think he did a good job
I think it did a good job
Ben says Tarantino gets to indulge his
pathological hatred of new zealanders as
well he did the same in Death Proof
yeah there was that one character that
she was only in it for like a few
minutes she was like in the flashback
yeah Judy yeah like so what was she
called six horse Judy or something like
that yeah she's just this cute chick
that just gets blowed up he doesn't like
new zealanders well I guess because that
character in Death Proof too she was
also in New Zealand okay uh Tom also Tom
Sykes says if you tie a Bowie knife to a
stick and use it as a spear you could
totally kill a bear with it now I think
the story he told is that the bear was
on top of him and he was sitting there
and he cut his throat and was stabbing
it to death and he survived it I think
that's oh wait a minute I might be
getting
um I think I might be getting
um confused with it with Daniel Boone or
Davy Crockett I think that might have
survived a bear attack
but I could have sworn him Jimbo he also
would tell all kinds of Lies
because he would sell those knives
evidently well yeah see we've got to
have a good Gotta Have a good story to
go with the [ __ ] right I mean they knew
that stuff way back then even though
even even though my understanding is
that uh his knife wasn't all that unique
that it was pretty much like all the
other knives well that's why that's even
more reason why you have to have like
really cool story to go with it because
otherwise I would be like why would I
want that one it's just the same as the
other one yeah they carried big knives
big survival knives
a lot of them so yeah Sly also brought
up uh the big silence
and it's kind of the same thing he said
unforgiving snow swept Frontier group of
bloodthirsty Hunters uh led by a vicious
Klaus Kinski is in it so we might see
that and a score by any of morricone
also yeah okay
Tammy said Davy Crockett killed him a
bear when he was only three that's right
he did
um yeah what you were saying before like
with this movie about this wearing uh
was that
um you know not only like Tarantino just
he loves loves loves the n-word he loves
to put as many instances as the n-word
as as he can in the in the movie
um I think I don't remember if somebody
counted this one but I saw a video
earlier that they did like a little kind
of like review of it and then at the end
like as a funny little thing they took
every single incident of somebody saying
that in the movie and like replaced it
with a different word yeah so it'd be
like every time somebody said and it was
just like random ass words like teacher
or hippopotamus or something like that
and it was like so [ __ ] funny like
the way it was edited together it was
like I got a feeling that's how they
talked though they Pro well that's what
I mean it's just kind of like it sounds
uh you know attack Indulgence it's very
Tacky by today's standards but uh that's
probably how they talk that's I was
thinking that while I was watching the
movie it's like from our point of view
it sounds like really excessive but I'm
I'm like that's probably how people
talked back then it might be like a
little overblown but probably not by
that much now that I'm thinking about it
uh Richard Brown did not like the big
silence he said it was actually quite
boring
uh Ben said my dear old grandmother
thought Bowie knives were invented by
David Bowie
are we absolutely sure that they're not
um Dave is here hey what's going on the
ridiculous six came out after a hateful
eight
[Laughter]
uh yeah how are you doing so wait what's
today it's Tuesday right yeah yeah yeah
uh Camp guy said I had to exchange words
for the n-word when I was reading
Huckleberry Finn to my kids
did you do a different word every time
or did you say or did you like come up
with uh with the same word
that's like pretty funny because like
yeah the the video as I can't remember
who it was maybe it was Joe Blow or
somebody like that but because he
started out like words that kind of
sounded like that like neighbor and
stuff like that but then like as it went
on it was just like random ass [ __ ]
words and it was just and there were so
many that it was just like funny like
seeing like each word that he came up
with all the time I'm like holy [ __ ]
that must have taken forever to edit
that [ __ ] together
but yeah so we watched this on Netflix
and Netflix has both versions it has the
theatrical cut now like I said
even when it came out in the theater in
2015.
uh Tarantino he had done a three hour
and two minute uh a Roadshow version
that he kind of like toured around where
because some theaters aren't really
equipped like for the 70 millimeter like
the super wide widescreen so he did it
for that
um that version and then he did like a
regular theatrical version that was two
hours and 47 minutes and that's the
version that we watched but Netflix also
has that they did in 2019 if you don't
know it's called the hateful eight
extended version and they actually broke
it up into four or five episodes
something like that I think it was like
four or five episodes and they're each
like 53 54 minutes long and they must
have added like a bunch more footage and
I think it was like I don't know if it's
all re-edited or if it's rearranged this
movie
um it's mostly because I feel like
Tarantino loves like um putty so it's
like stuff is not a chronological order
this one actually takes place almost
entirely in chronological order until
you get to the last chapter like it's
done in chapters and then you get to the
last chapter and then they do like a
flashback but it's not like Pulp Fiction
where it's just like all this stuff like
happening at different time frames and
you know overlapping and [ __ ] like that
and being like non-linear it's not it's
this one's kind of like pretty much
chronological until you get to the end
and then you flash back and it's like oh
this is what happened before they got
here you know what I mean but other than
that you know but yeah I mean like I
said great movie man I'm gonna put it up
there with some of my favorite westerns
it's a good Western
uh Sam Jackson knocks it out of the park
Russell knocking out of the park who's
the other the third guy the guy from
from predators what's his name
um wait I have a what is his name
Goggins Walter um Walton Goggins Walton
Goggins yeah yeah yeah yeah he was good
oh can I say that's real good I loved uh
Tim Roth in this yeah he was [ __ ]
great he's the hangman yeah yeah he was
good
I love Tim Roth anyway everybody was
good in it
um Dern was in it it wasn't what
Brewster was in it yeah uh he was good
in it
just uh Michael Madsen was in it yeah
from Reservoir Dogs yeah he's in it it
just uh everybody did a great job in it
and um
yeah what's his name gaggins no Goggins
Walton goggles Walton Goggins he does a
great job that's his name yeah his his
accent's okay he does a pretty okay
southern accent it's pretty good
um but I like the character that he
played
he was great and Predator assistant damn
guy on death row
I kind of feel like Predators it's like
that was that was actually like a really
good it's aged real well that's my
second favorite one that Predator yeah
mine too I think yeah yeah it's aged
real well and he was he has just created
that one too man he's like man when I
get home I'm gonna rape me some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah man four o'clock [ __ ] raping
time yeah
raped me so many [ __ ]
yeah yeah
[ __ ] funny man
I had to see that again man I want to
see Predators again yeah hell yeah four
o'clock
everyone knows that yeah yeah right
after T I want a gun give me a gun you
got two guns Mexican
[Laughter]
strawdog 78 said Walton Goggins was
awesome in the shield which is a TV show
like I said I kind of feel like he's
been in a bunch of movies but I feel
like he's mostly known for being in kind
of like like I said like Prestige TV
shows it's like I said I think he was
unjustified too as well yeah but I've
seen him in a bunch of stuff I like him
in Predators but this role is a lot
bigger he's got a lot more lines and
everything and I was like yeah he's like
a main character in this one big time
yeah like he's probably when this movie
came out 2015. okay so it's not that old
at all yeah it's all what is that seven
years seven years yeah yeah so yeah for
some reason I thought this was older
than that maybe I was thinking of Django
Unchained that was 2012. now I want to
see that one yeah they're showing that
for free
I think the uh you check Netflix because
I think they have a bunch of Tarantino
movies on there yeah
um
Tom Sykes says Walton Goggins blows his
head off in an episode of uh In the Heat
of the Night so there you go and uh Camp
guy said he was actually from the south
so he has a natural okay that's why
Richard Brown said have you seen bone
Tomahawk yes several times we actually
did a review of it probably a couple
years ago
Western horror
yeah good one good movie yeah it's right
it's basically like a straight up
Western until like the third act and
then it goes full-on [ __ ] survival
horror yeah it's great cannibals
yeah and that and that that one scene if
you know what if you've seen it you know
what we're talking about that one scene
is like probably one of the most the
nastiest thick [ __ ] thing you're ever
gonna see uh Ben says Django Unchained
is pretty good uh it's a Revenge fantasy
of Jews and blacks massacring plantation
owners yeah that's what I figured that's
what it is dude yeah yeah
you know we'll just kind of like in
glorious bastards was kind of like you
know a Nazi killing oh yeah fantasy like
you know burning over all the burning
Hitler and all that kind of stuff
um but yeah so Ben says time to split
yeah I kind of feel like Tom's getting
all yeah I'm getting antsy so cooking
downstairs that's right I keep
forgetting but yeah so tomorrow's
Wednesday which means that tomorrow
night is our you know Big Show and
because you know it's almost Christmas
time we're gonna do like kind of a
Christmas special
and uh so the patrons voted on tragedies
that happened at Christmas so it'll be
like a Christmas special but it'll
probably be kind of a bummer
but we'll do the fun Christmas show on
Friday night because we won't have a
topic necessarily so we can just like we
have some cookies or some [ __ ] like that
but yeah so uh I mean we'll still try to
have a good time with it even though I
was I was like doing the notes for it
today and I was like oh boy this is
gonna be kind of depressing oh well
maybe it'll make you feel like better
about your Christmas you know just by
like when Blake well at least my at
least that didn't happen to me so you
know what I mean that's what I figured
all right so uh hopefully everybody can
come by and see us tomorrow evening for
the main show we're gonna have some
drinks and we'll do some Christmas
tragedies it'll be super fun so uh
thanks for dropping by everybody and
we'll see you guys again tomorrow bye